hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science here chemistry phd skin care
known and sunscreen obsessey
i've had a lot of questions about
certain sunscreens with unusual claims
and what i think about them
so this video is about a couple of them
i'll be talking about what i personally
think of the claims that two different
products are making
there are a lot more products that other
people have suggested that i'll be
talking about a bit later so if you have
any suggestions leave them in the
comments
i like to talk to the company first to
try to understand how they came up with
the reasoning for their claim and then
try to compare that to what we know
about how sun protection works
i try to keep an open mind about these
sunscreen claims because there are a lot
of problems with how sunscreens work and
there are lots of scientists trying to
innovate
and come up with solutions for these
problems there are a lot of innovations
happening all the time and brands don't
make a lot of their information public
for competitive or legal reasons so you
can't really assume that something
doesn't work just because the public
information isn't there
you have to really dig and it usually is
smaller brands that are more innovative
bigger brands tend to not take a lot of
risks even if there is market demand
we've seen this again and again
where a smaller company does something
innovative and proves that it can work
and then larger companies tend to
hop on the trend or try to acquire the
smaller brand
on the other hand smaller brands
sometimes don't have the expertise or
experience to test their claims properly
and they end up making claims that
either don't work or
aren't allowed by law so it is a bit of
a mixed bag
so here are a couple of brands that a
lot of people have asked me about
and whether or not i think there is
enough evidence to back up their claims
a disclaimer here these are my opinions
i could be wrong but i have explained my
reasoning here
and what tests i think would actually
convince me of their claim
if you have reasons to disagree or if
there's evidence that i've missed
let me know in the comments if you like
nerding out about the science behind
beauty products click the like the
subscribe and the notification bell so
you don't miss any videos
[Music]
color science is a dermatologist
favorite and their most famous product
is their powder sunscreen
powder sunscreens are really promising
the idea that you could dust a powder
over your face and get enough sun
protection
would be amazing reapplying sunscreen
over makeup would be a breeze
the problem that everyone points out is
that you need a lot of powder on your
face to get even protection
but when i was working on my video about
reapplying sunscreen over makeup
i noticed that there were actually some
powder sunscreens that have really high
sps
and some of them even had water
resistance so the color science one is
spf 50 and 80 minutes water resistant
what that means is that for the label
test they applied the powder at two
milligrams per square centimeter on the
backs of people
the skin can be wet for this test and
then they
set them in a jacuzzi for 80 minutes and
then
after they came out of the jacuzzi they
retested that
patch of skin with the uv lamp and they
found that it was spf 50.
so that is really darn impressive for a
powder sunscreen
clearly the powder can cling onto skin
pretty well
but two milligrams per square centimeter
of powder is quite a lot
so i was a bit confused by this so i
emailed a bunch of powder sunscreen
companies asking them
how much powder they would expect people
to typically apply
and how much protection that powder
would be most of the brands i contacted
gave me a really generic
answer but color science actually
directed me to some data they submitted
to the fda
this data is publicly available it was
submitted to the fda
for inclusion in their sunscreen
monograph
so that powder sunscreens could be
considered an over-the-counter drug
so this data is meant to show that spf
50 is possible with normal application
of a powder sunscreen
it's also meant to show that powder
sunscreen is safe because there are some
concerns about inhalation
unfortunately the data doesn't really
convince me that spf 50
is normally expected for their powder
sunscreen
so the main study that works out how
much powder of consumers typically apply
to their face
is in attachment 2. first they surveyed
136 customers
on how long they typically apply their
powder sunscreen for
it was a multiple choice survey with
five options they were
30 to 60 seconds one to two minutes two
to three minutes three to four minutes
and greater than four minutes
these are the results they got they took
the shortest time in each bracket
and then averaged it all out and so they
got a minimum average application time
of 60.4 seconds
then they collected 10 measurements of
how much powder comes out of the tube in
60 seconds
the way they did this is they weighed
the tube at the start then they primed
the brush so this is tapping it and
flicking the brush until a puff of
powder comes out
then they got people to apply it for 15
seconds and then re-prime the brush and
do this repeatedly until they got up to
60 seconds
then they weighed the tube again at the
end and then subtracted it to work out
how much power would come out
on average this was 0.24 grams on a 360
square centimeter face this ended up
with 0.65 milligrams per square
centimeter
so with the spf water resistance test
that i talked about earlier
they actually wiped the powder off
people's backs and weighed it after the
chest and they found that
it was 0.542 milligrams per square
centimeter to get an spf
of 52. so based on this comparison they
figured that the average consumer
application would get greater than spf
52.
i think there are a lot of problems with
this method which would lead to them
overestimating the amount that a
consumer would
end up with on their face firstly the
time that people spent applying powder
sunscreen was self-reported
and self-reporting is notoriously
unreliable
this is especially the case with timing
we're all just really bad at estimating
time
remember at the start of the pandemic
when we all had to start washing our
hands for 20 seconds and it turned out
to be way longer than anyone expected
well because of this you can sort of
expect that these people are probably
overestimating how much time they're
spending applying
secondly the smallest bracket is 30 to
60 seconds
i don't know about you but when i apply
a typical face powder i take
about 5 seconds max obviously if you're
applying a powder sunscreen you're going
to try to apply it for longer but
whether or not you're gonna apply for
six times longer normally is really
questionable
30 seconds is three happy birthdays
which is a pretty long time
and a lot of people picked the lowest
time bracket we don't know if people
would have picked an even shorter time
bracket if that was an option
the other part of the methodology i
think also tends to bias towards
overestimating how much power you end up
with on your face
firstly it's measuring how much powder
came out of the tube not how much ends
up on your face
if you've ever applied powder you know
that you end up with a puff of powder
around you
not all of the powder that comes out
ends up on your face
even if it ends up on your face it
doesn't necessarily stay
on your skin there's also the priming of
the brush so they were tapping and
flicking the brush every 15 seconds
the instructions for the brush say to
tap and prime as necessary
not every 15 seconds there's also the
fact that when you prime it and flick it
there is powder going up into the air
and again not going on your face
there's actually another example of this
process in another part of the fda
submission
so this was to establish safety they had
a volunteer apply the powder to her face
while they were measuring how much
powder was coming out
around her face so the volunteer had
experience in using powder sunscreens
she primed the brush she applied three
layers to her face neck and shoulders
and then they weighed the brush
afterwards and they found that she used
between 0.06 and 0.18 grams of the
product over three trials
so this was a really low amount compared
to the 0.24 grams that they estimated
with the other method
and that 0.24 grams was only for the
face this was for face neck and
shoulders
this safety study was with an older
version of the brush and color science
say they've actually changed the brush
since then so that it flows better
even with the new brush though on the
product info page they estimate that
there's a 90 day supply with typical
usage
the product is 65 us dollars so it
doesn't seem like that bad a deal
but the brush only has six grams of
powder so if you assume that you're only
applying it all over your face once a
day
and all of the powder ends up on your
face which it won't because you are
meant to prime the brush and flick that
powder into the air
that only works out to be 0.19
milligrams per square centimeter of
application which is less than half of
what they claimed in their spf
protection test if each application was
actually 0.24 grams like they said in
the spf protection test
then it would only last 25 uses which is
not such a good deal after all
so color science doesn't really seem to
have a consistent estimate for typical
usage
it seems to change depending on which
source you're looking at
so the experiment that would convince me
is if they got customers to
apply the brush on their face like they
normally would without looking at the
time
then they could either weigh the brush
to see how much powder came out or even
better they could wipe the powder off
the skin like they did in the water
resistance test
and weigh how much there actually was i
would say getting a uv lamp and testing
the spf would be a better idea but
i don't think people are really willing
to get their faces burnt for science
i think it would also be pretty
interesting to see what 0.5 milligrams
per square centimeter of powder actually
looks like on the skin
color science also point out that they
have really high percentages of titanium
dioxide and zinc in their powder
and that you actually end up with more
of these active sunscreen ingredients on
your face when you apply
0.5 milligrams per square centimeter of
powder than if you apply
two milligrams per square centimeter of
a lotion
the problem is that the formula of the
lotion is there for a reason
it sticks those active ingredients onto
your face a lot better than with the
powder the powder can
fall off it also tends to clump up and
so you don't get even protection as you
would with
something that's smoother to apply so
overall i do think that this is one of
the best
if not the best powder sunscreens on the
market the water resistance data is
particularly impressive
but i just don't think powder sunscreens
work that well at the moment
especially with how people tend to apply
them and the way that the spf tests are
conducted
it's particularly unrealistic with
powders color signs of data showing that
people really prefer
powders and that people tend to reapply
them three times as much as they would
with other products
so it would be really great if a powder
product did actually work
but i just don't think the evidence is
there yet
[Music]
another brand that people have been
asking me about a lot is skinnies
skinnies is a new zealand brand and
they're famous for their claim that you
only need a pea-sized amount of their
sunscreen to cover your face
neck and ears their sunscreen doesn't
contain water so their argument is that
with a normal sunscreen you need to
apply more because that water will
evaporate off
and you end up with less product on your
face whereas with their sunscreen
you end up with just the active so it's
like you skip a step in your application
process you don't apply the water so you
don't need to apply as much
so here's the specific calculations they
do to get that pea size
they use 375 square centimeters as the
average male face
from their uva tests they measured that
1.3 milligrams per square centimeter has
an spf of 78.4
there are studies that have found that
on average the relationship between the
amount of sunscreen you apply and the
spf you get
is linear so that means applying 40 of
1.3 milligrams per square centimeter
will give you 40
of the spf this works out to be 195
milligrams for the 375 square
centimeters which works out to be half a
p
so they double it to be safe one of the
problems with this argument is
that not all sunscreens give a linear
relationship so that means if you apply
40
of the required amount you might not
actually get 40
of the spf you might get less the bigger
problem is that skin
is bumpy there are valleys in your skin
that generally need to be filled in
before the heels of your skin get any
coverage
so when you apply less sunscreen you
don't just get a thinner layer you
actually get a patchy layer
it's like applying watercolor paint
straight out of the tube versus applying
it after you've diluted it with water
when you have it with water you can
apply it over a larger surface more
evenly
if you have a blob of really thick paint
you can't get even protection over that
whole area
so even though you have the same amount
of paint you end up with a very
different final product
again water is inactive but it is in the
product for a reason
skin being bumpy is actually why
sunscreens are tested at two milligrams
per square centimeter
studies have found that people normally
apply less than this but they still have
to test it at two milligrams per square
centimeter
because that's how much you need for
consistent results the reason for this
is probably because of that patchy
application if you have patchy
application it's unevenly patchy and so
you end up with inconsistent results
you need to have that two milligrams per
square centimeter to fill in the valleys
and start covering the hills
with a product like sunscreen you want
to be able to confidently say that most
people applying the right amount
in an even layer will get the expected
spf and so unpredictable results just
aren't acceptable
it's possible that this particular
sunscreen applies really really
evenly and so you don't have this
problem with needing a larger amount
but this would be unusual behavior for a
sunscreen
so to support that this unusual behavior
actually happens you would need good
evidence
skinnies have said that they've tried to
get the sunscreen tested at lower
amounts but
labs have been turning them back because
it's not standard protocol
this is a problem with innovative
sunscreen products it can be really hard
to test them and it's really frustrating
and it sucks
but i think for a claim like this you do
need to test that tiny amount on skin
and see what happens and see what
happens for a number of people
i do think that the way that sunscreens
are tested and regulated can hold back
innovation
there are strict rules around what you
can and can't claim and
a lot of these things are things that
would actually improve the user
experience and user safety
but these rules do also protect users
from using sunscreens improperly which
is
really really common i do think skinny
sunscreens are really cool and
innovative
i've been sent some pr samples and i've
tried them and they do feel really
spreadable so i think it is quite
possible that a p
size amount could work but i just don't
think they have enough evidence to be
able to make this recommendation yet
they do say they have 10 years of user
experience and they're trying to get
this evidence
but i don't think that's enough so
remember this is just my opinion about
what these companies claim
what do you think are there any other
products that you want me to look into
as well
i hope you liked this video if you did
you can give it a thumbs up and
subscribe you can also follow me on
instagram at lab muffin beauty slice and
check out my blog for more of the
science behind beauty products
see you next time to nerd out more
you